à voir
je vais vous inviter dans une aventure
personnelle je suis désolé de pareils de
moi mais j'essaie de vous renvoyer la
balle après pour vous c'est sa part
d'une d'abord d'une difficulté depuis
l'enfance et j'ai essayé de faire de mon
corps à laboratoire pour être en bon
état lors j'étais en mauvais état au
départ horrible santé alors tout part de
là je suis comme vous je suis né dans le
corps d'une maman et c'est intéressant
parce que c'est une forme de nutrition
très intéressante
c'est la maman va de nourrir non pas par
la bouche mais par le nombril par le
cordon ombilical et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est le ventre ce
dont on parle maintenant de deuxième
cerveau c'est une zone très intime c'est
pas le même circuit
c'est tout à fait autre chose et on sait
aussi que par le sang on a aussi les
émotions de la maman donc on est
vraiment dans un univers qui est
complètement à la fois de l'ordre
nutritionnel mais qui est beaucoup plus
un mec qui est quelque chose de
fusionnel
il ya un rapport très important avec la
maman il ya une sorte de certainement de
complicité qui se fait j'ai oublié vous
aussi sûrement mais on peut imaginer
quand même que c'est un temps très
important pour nous tous
surtout grandi que tout se passe avant
trois ans mais je pense que le temps
intra-utérin était est essentiel puisque
on a annoncé en a déjà mis des micros à
l'intérieur du ventre et on sait que
l'enfant entend canton l'enfant qui a
par exemple à sept mois
ils entendent tout ce qui se passe dans
la pièce donc c'est vécu là sont très
importants pompe pour me pour moi bon
j'ai eu un petit démarrage un peu
brusque mais mère meurt pendant ma
naissance il a bon je suis un bébé alors
au départ normal sur un beau bébé ça
veut dire bus normal on va ne sentais
rien de choses particulières par contre
très très vite je passais demain en vain
de main en main pendant des années et
donc très très vite
je vais devenir chétif asthmatiques
rachitique et puis sans défenses
immunitaires
sous antibiotiques pendant plus de la
moitié de l'année et donc je vais me
retrouver dans une situation de lutte de
mal de vivre en fait c'est pour ça que
après ce que je vais proposer c'est un
tour du monde de 15 ans pour me former
et c'est pour trouver des solutions pour
moi mais je reviens quand même à cette
première période
donc j'ai eu la période de nutrition
intra utérine et puis j'ai une deuxième
maman à l'âge de 5 ans alors là c'est la
nuit à la nourriture normande la crème
le trait carnet tout bon c'est trop trop
sucrés trop gras trop et c est donc ce
continue à plonger parce que mon corps
est trop faible pour tout ça et puis un
jour du jour au lendemain eh bien je
vais tout couper je vais faire comme les
chats vous avez sasp urgent que je vais
manger de la salade
je vais manger des herbes aromatiques eu
tout ce que je sentais instinctivement
donc pour ça j'ai plus de rage je mange
que sol en fait dans mon coin et je vais
petit à petit me nettoyer d'abord
d'abord il faut nettoyer
on pense toujours à ce que l'on doit
manger est d'abord quand il ya trop il
faut nettoyer et puis surtout eh bien je
vais de petit à petit commencé à
m'orienter une fois j'ai nettoyé à me
reconstruire depuis le végétal je sens
est activement que le végétal est ce qui
va briguer libre et je savais pas encore
j'avais déjà des connaissances à des
médecines à lui revendique etc mais
c'était encore que qq débauche et donc
je vais me mettre je vais pas devenir
végétarien mais végétalien un sens sous
produits animaux donc bah céréales yens
légumineuses etc
et pendant onze ans je vais reconstruire
mon corps c'est à dire je serai plus
malades
là maintenant ça doit faire 35 ans j'ai
pas vu un médecin et que j'ai pris j'ai
pas fait une des prises de sang autre
chose c'est une autre vie quoi bon c
et donc au départ ça a été végéta lien
pour me reconstruire
et puis ensuite eh bien j'ai parcouru le
yo yo en même temps par ensuite pendant
ces onze ans j'ai parcouru le monde
après mes études universitaires qui me
plaisait pas c'était trop trop médicale
classique j'ai je suis parti en chine je
partis en inde j'ai parti au tibet ou en
thaïlande à peu près tout et là j'ai
étudié tous les systèmes alors d'abord
les médecines local médecine ayurvédique
médecine chinoise mais les techniques
qui vont avec
donc les techniques corporelles par les
massages dans l'échappée de chaque pays
les techniques personnelles discipline
personnelle comme le yoga en inde avec
la méditation comme le tai chi kong tous
à jésus a donc je suis devenu professeur
de ces différentes disciplines
et puis et puis eh bien j'ai rencontré
les histoires de ces différents pays et
je vais faire des petites histoires pour
voir comment c'est dans certains pays
la nourriture est totalement lié on peut
dire au spirituel on va très sobre à la
manière d'être
c'est que je ne mange pas qu'un aliment
je mange des émotions de l'aliment je
mange de l'énergie c'est en asie c'est
essentiel je mange également des
éléments il ya des aliments qui vont
éveiller la conscience qu'ils vont nous
rendre plus plus épuré plus peu près à
vivre différemment même au niveau
émotionnel leur première histoire c'est
un samouraï qui va avoir un grand m
avantage donc c'est quelqu'un de très
modeste qui dans son petit coin en fait
on va dire et il lui dit mais je
voudrais savoir où commence la porte de
l'enfer est également où commence la
porte du paradis et le savez monsieur
qui est là puis commence à toi un
soudard qui sent mauvais qui est en
train de tuer des gens etc
tu voudrais avoir la spiritualité mais
pour qui tu te prends
t'as vu comment tu es tu et ignoble que
le samouraï qui ramène très arrogant
entrées illégales son katana
il est prêt à couper en deux lemoine
hélas le moine lui dit et là commence la
porte de l'enfer et l'a aussitôt le
comprends ils se prosternent je vous
dise il est là comment ça pour du
paradis j'aime bien ces petites
histoires parce que maintenant si on le
met par exemple au niveau d'alimentation
si je suis arrogant comme samurai si je
pense que je suis maître du monde et que
l'aliment qui est la valve aliments on
prend pour que nous les lâchetés on
l'achète sur moi c'est sais je suis un
être supérieur qui va coloniser le monde
qui va manger parfois nerveusement qui
va le faire avec une certaine violence
hélas cette violence va avoir des
incidences dans mon corps là commencent
les portes de l'enfer
la lente descente dans un vieillissement
prématuré ou dans des maladies qui
peuvent venir progressivement parce que
on n'est pas dans une dent dans une
disposition qui est fait pour l'harmonie
du corps des émotions et du mental et
puis par contre si à me donner cet
aliment jeu dans la dimension tantrique
alors on entre on parle toujours des
aspects sexuels mais c'est bien deux
éléments ça peut être la pomme et moi
par exemple si cette pomme j'essaie
d'être de même nature c'est une vie à la
pomme ou un animal autre chose c'est une
vie qui va me servir à stimuler ma
propre vie si je la reçois avec la
recevoir déjà rien que c'est le voile à
la sellerie se marient douceur en moins
avec conscience avec gratitude et bien à
ce moment là elle va mourir complètement
différemment
et là c'est pas le paradis mais déjà on
est en train de développer une qualité
de vie qui est plus facile plus
lumineuse et qui est plus en
interrelation avec le monde mais on
n'est plus remonté en échange on n'est
pas au fond de soi même en train de
manger et de posséder
voilà c'est une première histoire il y
en a une deuxième que j'aime bien aussi
ce sont deux moines un vieux car
beaucoup d'expérience et puis un moignon
l'arrêter le mans et puis ils n'ont pas
le droit de toucher une femme mais quand
je pas dû toucher pas sexuellement ou
juste de même de frôler en fait bon et
il arrive au bord d'une rivière
hélas là il ya une très très jolie femme
la rivière est en crue est dit est ce
que vous pourriez vous m'aider à passer
j'ai peur d'être emporté par les flots
ni une ni deux cas marine lemoine la
messe sur son dos traverse la dépose la
salut et continue son chemin petit moine
qui est là qui dans sa tête
oui mais quand même les préceptes
problème
bon et puis au bout d'un certain temps
il ose dire mais mais mais cette femme
voilà mon fils je la porte encore et ça
c'est toute la pensée zen qui veut dire
que souvent des dents les ruminations en
entretien on va la gonfle mêmes essais
deux par rapport à la nourriture c'est
pareil parfois c'est obsessionnel
on est dans une sorte de mise en marche
de la journée à peine commencée il ya
des gens il sait qu'est ce qu'on mange
ce midi et que c'était on est déjà en
train de ne pas être dans l'instant
présent et ce que j'ai appris avec
l'asie c'est être ici maintenant et ça
ça change tout
si alors que je suis donc dans mes
recherches mes études je suis entre les
traditions un transition de différentes
de différents continents va dire et les
neurosciences aussi et bien si je suis
en pleine conscience je suis ici
maintenant
déjà mes cellules sont prêtes vous avez
3 milliards da cellule elle s'éveille
elles sont là prête et avec ça il ya des
neurones peut-être 760 milliards de
neurones qui sont là pour créer toutes
ses communications
vous êtes disponible pour un relationnel
différent parce que dans l'instant
présent
on est ouvert on a dans le verdon
réveille nos potentialités
alors que si je suis fermé au fond de
moi même bien j'écrase les choses par
exemple là on les chais sont vraiment
pas mal et vous maintiennent assez
droite essayait d'être si vous acceptez
totalement verticale l'avc de vous
positionner bien être les pieds bien à
plat comme ça rien que ça par exemple
voyez le ventre il est ouvert là or
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on mange
très souvent plein de gens ils sont leur
soupe là ici etc ou les travers en etc
qu'est ce qui se passe sur le ventre il
est tout petit mon ventre donc vous
comprenez bien que on peut pas recevoir
un animal un aliment on peut pas
recevoir un aliment depuis une
crispation un bon espace si déjà vous
vous ouvrez essayé je peux recevoir
puisque ça si je suis verticale je suis
dans ce que les chinois appellent entre
ciel et terre est bien dans ce ciel et
terre je suis plus capable de recevoir
la grâce on sait qu'une ressource guérir
que ce soit religieux enfin d'un
principe divin ou cosmique dans beaucoup
d'endroits c'est cosmique je suis un
microcosme en résonance avec le
macrocosme en fait mais je suis en
interrelation il ya une manière d'être
qui va s'ouvrir au monde
s'ouvrir à des choses beaucoup plus
large que le corps lui même d'ailleurs
dans la matière même du corps il ya
aussi à des supports qui sont très
subtiles
ce que dix mois devenu moins l'inde
l'india dans la matière de choses près à
critiquer la matière et brouch acquis et
l'essence sont nés entre l'effet de
substances et d'essence mais cette
manière de se positionner verticale déjà
c'est une réalité qu'on peut appliquer
tout de suite l'idée c'est que partie
avec des petits éléments le sait on le
fait pas c'est votre vie mais on nous a
jamais vraiment appris à l'école être
verticale nous a jamais appris à
respirer
or la respiration est un élément
essentiel dans toute l'asie on respire
plus que chez nous nous on respire
sportif savez en courant c'est toujours
un effort c'est toujours un acte
respiratoires alors pu respirer
c'est un échange c'est l'air qui vient
d'extérieur qui rentrent en moi et qui
repart sur l'extérieur et un échange il
ya cette notion de recevoir c'est plus
encore quelque chose de muscles et de
deux volontaires la respiration
en plus on sait maintenant il ya
beaucoup de disciplines qu'utilisait
respiration va jouer à la fois sur le
corps sur les émotions et sur le mental
plus vous avez une respiration longues
paisibles et bien plus vous harmonisez
les trois les trois domaines or le
principe principal aliment avant tous
les autres c'est l'air
parce que un aliment qui rentrent en
vous s'il n'y a pas d'air il ne sert et
sert à rien vous mettez un feu lalime
ans et c'est une sorte de combustible
qui va entrer encore qui va dire un
nutriment qui va arriver dans la cellule
et qui va pouvoir brûlé mais si vous
avez un peu vous êtes un coup d'oeil par
dessus le feu s'éteint si vous respirez
a suffisamment eh bien il va pas y voir
une bonne combustion et petit à petit si
vous respirez très peu et il ya des gens
qui ont une respiration extrêmement
faibles entre autres certaines personnes
âgées bien sûr eh bien il n'y a plus la
possibilité de stimuler le métabolisme
cellulaire qui rament la base de notre
vie en fait donc une respiration ample
paisible plus j'allonge mon souffle
semble éssoufflé plus j'appelle les
émotions et en même temps plus jugé
veille la conscience est ce que j'ai
appris mais qui est confirmé par les
neurosciences et une région 6/10 quoi et
bien l'être humain à cinq
caractéristiques 5 facture du vivant
d'abord il respire
il se nourrit il se défend défenses
immunitaires multiplication cellulaire
vous vous coupez ça serait pas il pense
et il ya des émotions et tout ça est
bien confirme ce que les traditions ont
découvert alors il ya une autre histoire
mais je voudrais partir de m dos guen
qui est un des grands maîtres c'est au
xiiie siècle au japon et ses livres aux
séries de chine et il va développer des
monastères et il va mettre le dancehall
et enzo c'est le cuisinier il va mettre
cuisinier dans les fonctions supérieures
du monastère dans les mots la fonction
même donc spirituelle du monastère et
pourquoi parceque il à dire que ce qui
est important c'est à la fois la qualité
de la nourriture
c'est plus que ça c'est la manière
d'être pendant 7
cette préparation c est en plus la
préparation c'est un cadeau que l'on
fait aux autres donc toute une dimension
qui est qui dépasse à personne et
surtout et bien par la conscience par
les infinis petites choses on va pouvoir
développer une conscience plus large
plus je suis sur les petites choses plus
je vais pouvoir ouvrir en conscience sur
plus grand parce que je suis disponible
j'ai pu esprits et qui part sur
différentes choses à la fois et donc il
va mettre des noms comme comme vraiment
le chef spirituel important si ce n'est
pas le supérieur général mais il est
dans les grands les grands décideurs et
là je voyais à une autre histoire comme
ça il ya deux jeunes qui entendent
parler de de l'enseignement de m dos
guen et ils vont partir de monastères au
monastère c'est quelques siècles plus
tard il n'arrive pas à trouver un
monastère où les gens sont totalement
dans le coup la conscience de chaque
moment de chaque aliment manger de
chaque geste l'ont fait par rapport à la
préparation par ou dans leur pain ou
après le repas il faut bien sûr nettoyer
ils sont déçus de plus en plus est bon
il essaye une dernière fois un dernière
dernier monastère on leur a dit que là
c'est quand même différent tous les
autres et donc ils passent ce dernier
visage ils savent que après il ya plus
qu le monastère il ya un petit ruisseau
qui est là donc là ils sont quand même
plein d'espoir ils sont prêts à monter
trouver enfin la l'enseignement qui leur
convient et qu'est ce qu'il y voit
descendre le long du ruisseau une
carotte commença le cuisinier a laissé
passer une carotte de laisser partir
dans le dans le ruisseau et là ils sont
totalement désespéré s'est pas encore là
qu'il ya l'enseignement de la pleine
conscience comme il le souhaiterait
ils font demi tour puis à ce moment là
ils entendent quelqu'un qui court la
essoufflé vivre vieux moine qui est là
vous n'avez pas fait passer une carotte
alors là il éclate de rire il court avec
le moine chercher la carotte
ils montrent bien sûr au monastère
trouver l'enseignement qui leur convient
on a toujours cette notion entre
l'aliment et on va dire une manière
d'être ou ne voient là une manière de
changer le mental et émotionnel
alors il ya il ya d'autres histoires
branger j'ai étudié avec mitch kuchi
donc qui a été le chef de file après la
macrobiotique et donc été le disciple de
georges ozawa et donc les jeunes
étudiants et donc il y aura contagion
dit voilà j'étais avec avec george
george zaoual fonds dalton avant de
vaincre biotique puis à une fête
macrobiotique qui se préparait lui
diront ils nous embêtent les eaux on va
sortir dehors et donc là bien sûr
macrobiotique ont des végétaliens
c'était vraiment la nourriture est une
et d'une énergie un bon d'équilibré
ligne en fait les cinq éléments comme en
médecine chinoise et puis surtout un
travail sur la conscience la récipient
la manière de cuir c'est un creuset
alchimique le corps lui-même est vu
comme un creuset le chimique pour la
nourriture devant l'ordre des choses
très très sérieuse on va dire trop
sérieuse alors dans ce cas il y a
georges qui alors voilà à wimby un fast
food et c'était il ya longtemps on avait
très peu encore au japon et est donc il
rentre là et puis dit donc un bijou
coucher mais qu'est ce que tu prends un
autre vue l'enseignement du comme vous
et puis dit alors ah les deux hamburgers
alors qu'est ce que tu vois comme vous
allez de coca il l'a miccio dit quand
j'ai vu avec quel plaisir
ils mangeaient cette nourriture et bien
j'étais colle complètement scotché j'ai
compris que la manière de manger était
plus importante encore que l'aliment
manger ça c'est un élément très
important et donc il y a demandé et puis
en plus j'étais tellement époustouflé
que c'est lui qui a fini ma part
ailleurs voilà et c'est bien parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'intolérance en fait on n'est
pas intolérants on n'est pas dans une
dans une secte nutritionnelle dans une
chapelle etc c'est simplement comprendre
que l'on peut faire on peut faire des
écarts mais si tous les jours mais les
écarts à notre corps est en déséquilibre
un écart temps en temps c'est très bien
et moi quand j'étais donc au japon dont
je vois les noms beaucoup monaster
japonais c'était assez austère et puis
je suis allé au dojo de mishima de d'un
personnage qui était médecin détroit
médecine et c'était le le dojo du chiva
donc avec passage rookie sennecey j'ai
juste une petite parce que j'ai pas de
jets potter c'est fini c'est au japon
que commencer
et donc non marché j'ai fini autrement
je vous pourrez faire une coupure après
ça sera possible ou pas voilà donc la
seule chose s'ils avaient quelque chose
à retenir pour vous soyez verticale
respirer déjà pendant les repas avant le
repas respirait plus respirer pendant le
repas et puis surtout penser positif
essayer de sentir que vous avez de la
chance de la gratitude de recevoir un
aliment c'est pas anodin il ya des gens
sur cette année le savent bien qu'ils ne
mangent pas à leur faim
mais même si on mange ce n'est pas faux
pas le prendre ça comme des êtres
supérieurs
on doit le prendre avec bonheur et pour
peu qu'on partage et bien la vie
parfaite
merci beaucoup